Oh what is going on YouTube now one of
my favorite pastimes on earth it's going
out to eat food is it drug you know I
know you love food is when you sing and
dance when the food comes out I've got a
sandwich what every time you go out to
eat better it's always that one
cheap-ass [ __ ] that never wants
to pay for his or her part of the bill
I'm sick that [ __ ]
and if you're offended by this in any
way then a space is probably because
it's you so yeah we know what it is LGI
baby let's get it out why is it that
every time a bill comes up you suddenly
get quiet and [ __ ] huh well maybe if I
don't say nothing they won't notice I
didn't pay mother you ghetto piece of
[ __ ] I wish the worst upon you I want
you to take a butter knife and chop your
face off every [ __ ] time we go
out
everybody's tip and tax pays for your
part of the film and then you have the
audacity to saying come we all have any
money left over for the tip y'all ever
notice that the chickens one in your
group always had the nicer [ __ ] nice
cars nice clothes but you can't pay for
a cheeseburger ya [ __ ] chief of the
clown cop number one time you do pig
food you never cover the tip attacks all
sheepies you never knew there wasn't
Texas you have lived in California your
whole life but suddenly you forgot that
people tax to ass I hate it when people
lie about simple [ __ ] especially when
they're not good at it and every time
you confront them about the life they
start selling this [ __ ] like you're
speaking in tongue hey what's this 3
bucks with the tip and tax uh you were
up it's uh we uh what uh I'm gonna find
out mark
God and another thing stop rounding down
your bill
how does 1099 be you pay $10
school dropout slap you in the face and
don't do that talking it up [ __ ] when
the bill comes out because I invented
that and when they sit around and chop
it up and they try to distract you when
that part of the bill comes out what do
you have to make your friend feel like
they have to rob you for you to pay for
the part of the bill that you all I know
there's a part where I will count so you
should probably pay my bill downtown you
ever noticed when you passed in the
village it's excited to go deaf and
blind here's the buildup hey the bill
who's doing oh you oh you unless you
came here to see me ha take the bill hey
[ __ ] about the money any bus food
it's the fact that you think that you
can get away with it that's the issue
and if you can't pay for that [ __ ] do a
normal kettle people do go to McDonald's
buy couple double cheeseburgers and then
eat that [ __ ] before you go to your real
meal [ __ ] that's what I did
why don't you think I got a body like
this rome wasn't built in one day said
oh gosh and which do pay Hey what is
going on YouTube before I go ahead and
sign out I got the tail y'all if you
guys haven't noticed or do not know I'm
a huge fan of SNL if you guys don't know
what SNL is you should probably go I
don't know kill yourself so if you ever
wondered what the people do at SNL over
their off time during the summer well
this is what they did on a channel
called above average they basically do
skits and comedy sketches with
celebrities and guest appearances which
I'm pretty sure you guys will all enjoy
I'm a huge fan of SNL once again so um
what y'all can do is go ahead and pick
them out at the above average channel at
the entity the link below
it's where y'all can enjoy all this
comedy fun this and I'm pretty sure if
you guys don't enjoy it then something's
wrong with you when you're dead on the
inside so but yeah click that link below
and subscribe to the channel and uh
Hollenbeck exit boy because something
I'm trying to say something very
definitive right now everybody has a
signature goodbye I don't like the only
one on u2 doesn't have one hook line and
sinker ha ha
can't pay my hands behind my back the
[ __ ] is that a transformer fight outside
god damn it don't stop now what up Oh
Oh bring it back stop Oh rub it now